what do you think happens to reach out I
mean we have a massive implosion of
malls in the United States mm-hmm which
is going to be a problem because well
it's good problem for people on the
moors yeah we're putting that aside it's
a problem for society you think that it
is a continuing trend the big the most
exploded on the backs of a department
store and I'm operating under a sort of
assumption that if like what department
store started like in 1860 under John
Wanamaker and like via chop if I operate
on the assumption that the department
store is a dead branch of the larger
history of retail they became like I
mean it's not never going to go away and
it's gonna be the right form factor for
certain things especially perishables
but the department stores became really
really big based on solving for the
solution right because this is
essentially like this customer
experience there's distribution and this
value also free things you can optimize
in you pick two of us so the
department's also really good at Bayer
and we go to the solution usually the
first time your department store came
into your city as well as first time the
cause became available for you and that
was a big event and then people bought
these products and these department
stores got really big now we enter
completely it takes that order of
equation so distribution is now like a
commodity and everyone has it
automatically it so bright because
packaged delivering got so good and
same-day delivery is further gonna do
that which means having access means
nothing exactly so which means that all
the department stores can do with each
other is like compete on there because
they have zero history of computing on
experienced